professor stefan alexander is a
theoretical physicist and a cosmologist
at brown's university in addition to
being a prolific musician in this
episode we cover his theory of
everything called the autodidactic
universe a model he developed in
conjunction with lee smolin as well as a
few other luminaries listed here the
laws of physics can be approximated by
matrix models we talk about this and
machine learning deals well with matrix
models so a natural question arises is
there a relationship between the two can
the universe learn its own laws in a
manner analogous to unsupervised
learning let's say of a restricted
boltzmann machine click on the time
stamp in the description if you'd like
to skip this intro for those new to this
channel my name is kurt jaimungal i'm a
filmmaker with the background in
mathematical physics interested in
explicating what are called theories of
everything from a theoretical physics
perspective but as well as delineating
the possible connection consciousness
has to the fundamental laws of the
universe provided these laws exist at
all and are knowable to us generally
conversations on physics and
consciousness tend to stay at a cosmetic
level
not going past or rarely moving past
even the double slit experiment or the
stern gerlach experiment in these
podcasts we tend to delve into
intricacies into equations sometimes
into meticulous technicalities and so
forth because number one it's tedious to
hear about the measurement problem for
the 25th time number two because it
seems like the language or large part of
the language at which the universe
expresses itself is mathematical then if
one wants to understand the most
profound enigmas of the universe some
mathematical facility is necessary and
number three because you can handle it
most of the time i find that the public
purveyors of science simplify overly so
because they're still assuming that
you're the average passive listener of
say cable news but what i found is that
there's not only a hunger for in-depth
specialized conversation on these
seemingly abstruse topics but that the
intelligence of the average listener
perhaps even the average person has been
vastly underestimated that is there's a
thirst so that's like curiosity and then
there's the ability to quench that
thirst and that's something like
intelligence or astuteness mainly people
have focused on the curiosity aspect
while neglecting the brightness of you
if you'd like the notes from this
podcast in pdf form then check the
description there's also links to the
discord where conversations occur on
psychology consciousness and physics and
there's a link to the patreon that is
patreon.com slash kirchheim uncle if
you'd like to support this channel there
would be almost no way for me to have
conversations of this fidelity on the
topics of consciousness theoretical
physics string theory loop even
geometric unity which i'll tackle at
some point if i wasn't able to do this
full time the sponsors and the patrons
are what allow for that so thank you so
much again that's patreon.com
kurtjmungle
c-u-r-t-j-a-i-m-u-n-g
with regard to sponsors there are three
algo is an end-to-end supply chain
optimization software company with
software that helps business users
optimize sales and operations planning
to avoid stockouts reduce returns and
inventory write-downs while reducing
inventory investment it's a supply chain
ai that drives smart roi headed by a
bright individual by the name of amjad
hussein who's been a huge supporter of
this podcast since nearly its inception
the second sponsor is brilliant
brilliant illuminates the soul of math
science and engineering through
bite-sized interactive learning
experiences you can even learn group
theory which is what's being referenced
when you hear that the standard model is
predicated on u1 cross su 2 cross su-3
those are called league groups visit
brilliant.org tow to get 20 off the
annual subscription and don't stop
before four lessons at least that's what
i found the third sponsor is
curiositystream and they're joining us
for the first time there's something
approximately like the netflix for nerds
or the hulu for history buffs or the
disney plus for the scientist in you go
to curiositystream.comtoetoe
for unlimited access to the world's top
documentaries and non-fiction series
more on them later thank you and enjoy
this conversation with stefan alexander
i've been looking forward to this for
quite some time
same here
so brian told me that i should look into
you and at first i just thought you were
not interested in theories of everything
just a physicist working in some
particular field of physics but it turns
out that what you're interested in is
almost exactly what this channel is
interested in namely theories of
everything you also surmise about
consciousness but that's more in your
book
so we'll talk about the autodidactic
universe
we'll touch on
some of churn simon's modified gravity
i went back and read one of your
seminal papers inflation
brain annihilation from around 2001. oh
yeah
my little string theory days yep and
then quantum cosmological constant i
only got to skim that briefly
okay do you have any questions for me
before we get started
let's dive in the way that
this is meant to be treated is as if you
have an imbecile across from you
in office hours who's extremely curious
so i'm going to be asking you can you
define this term this term this year
this office hours forget about
an external audience
okay gotcha
okay that sounds like that sounds like
the problem is that i'm probably going
to be the imbecile but that's okay
okay well why don't you give the
audience an overview of your
autodidactic universe theory
sure well it's um the theory is um you
know was started by in
for a couple years of conversations
between uh it starts roots with um
independent conversation that
lee smolin
and my
my friend colleague jaron lanier the
virtual reality pioneer we've been all
three of us have been friends for a long
time so you know we as with friends i
mean john is a computer scientist and
other things you know multi
instrumentalists and but anyway so you
know we have our side chats you know we
talk over the years
um about things about matters that um
[Music]
are scientific and not scientific and
over the years it our conversation all
coalesce into this
this um
thing about whether or not well first of
all lee and john has over the years have
their own side conversations about
whether physical laws can can learn
um physical systems could learn their
own laws types that type of idea
um and use an idea some evolutionary
theory
i kind of came in at it with jaron
and also lee separately
um
thinking about fundamental theories like
you know theories of quantum gravity or
unified theories and just looking at
them structurally
um
that
the observation is that
you know
what one interesting fact is that if you
look at for example string theory
and you look at loop quantum gravity and
you look at you know
other approaches to quantum gravity
um even the original ideas of super
membrane theory the idea that the
fundamental degree of freedom is really
a membrane
not a string and
when people tried to quantize this
membrane
it
they ran into problems and they found
out that oh look at this this membrane
theory
um
could be
properly quantized if you turn it into a
matrix theory so the end of day all
these approaches to quantum gravity
pointed to
matrix theories okay and what do i mean
by matrix theories if i'm sure
you might want to know that
but
sorry i'm curious so as far as i
understand i'll just tell you and then
you can correct me because it helps me
learn
especially because i put myself on the
line my ego on the line
better okay so as far as i understand
with the matrix models
you just mentioned that it solves a
particular issue but another issue is
created in that they're finite
dimensional and what you want to do is
take n to infinity
isn't that correct
one of the things you can do to make
contact with the continuum or of
um for example um
young mills like theories which are
um is that yeah that's right when you
take n where n is the rank of the matrix
so ever if n is two i have a two by two
matrix so when n goes infinity the rank
goes to infinity that it does reduce
back to
known theories like yang mills theories
for example
now
something that occurs to me right now as
i think about the and okay let's let's
take n to infinity would that not be a
countable infinity whereas the
infinities that we deal with with lead
groups and so on are uncountable they're
the reals so how is it that we can take
a matrix blow it up to n and get
something that's something like this
real continuum
um that's a good question um
it's similar to you know when you
you do a fourier series you know you
have a you take that sum
and
and you you you look at basically the
sum of sines and cosines and then you
when you take basically
n in that sum
to infinity that becomes the integral
sign so it's the so it's similar to the
continuum
um
hypothesis
um i see
yeah okay continue
yeah no pun intended
um
yeah so
so in a nutshell it the observation that
i made with lee smolin and lee made with
me is that oh how interesting uh matrix
models seem to under underlie a couple
of what we thought to be disparate um
approaches to quantum gravity or
unification string theory loop point of
gravity um and other other ways um you
know random matrix models they all kind
of see
membrane theory they all point to these
matrix models so
maybe we should take more seriously that
the matrix models themselves might
actually be
well not might actually be i mean banks
fishler shanker and suskin so-called
bfss
and i think ikkt named after
some japanese theorists
um
actually conjectured that
m theory which is
supposed to be the you know the
unification of all string theories um
m theory or the so-called
non-perturbative definition of string
theory it was hypothesized to be a
matrix theory
so
we weren't saying anything new there
but to maybe extend that extend it
beyond even m theory to say that other
approaches of quantum gravity um might
also have this so that was one one
observation the second observation that
me john and lee made
um
was that if you look at the equations of
a matrix model
it has a semblance
to
you know
um artificial some
it has a symbolism that's it's not
identical but it has a resemblance to
artificial neural network it resembles
it how
um it might be useful for me to then to
write something sure please
um
so
and i'm gonna be very um schematic here
sure because i'm writing from memory
and i so okay
so just recall that an artificial neural
network basically tells me that if i
have you know a simple two layered if i
have
an input
so here's my x so x is a vector it's an
n couplet right
um
that i can it could you know that e
think of each point here each dot is a
neuron that could be connected
you know in a forward way right i can
have connection
to
let me call this thing right um right so
oops my bad
i don't know why it's doing that uh are
you able to hear any weird sounds yep no
no no
okay
that's what i get right here so the
equation says that if i if i um there's
some output
um y
right
and there's a weight
matrix that determines how
how correlated or how um connected
these neurons are so for example
x1 right
if i have x
x oh sorry x1 and then i have
um y1 for example right this w i j
will denote basically
this is x j
and this is y
i
right so this basically tells me
how every neuron is connected um
you know the output is connected to the
input right
and and then of course there's some bias
term here that basically helps out with
um
to further basically you know to help
with bias and these connections all
right so that's
there's a long story here
um
about um neural networks
sure and um all right so now this is
very similar to um
statistical inference right if i
basically have um
in this case a line
and i tell you the slope of the line i
can adjust the slope of the line
basically to basically um fit
to fit some data right given an input
um
you know the y the output will basically
map you know sort of um
maximize or
the slope will basically maximize
in this case if you try to get the best
um standard dev you know
mean
um
you can basically
um
use this this is a multi-dimensional
version of statistical inference i see i
see okay okay
now
the mate
um
the matrix
so one thing to take notice of here is
that
mathematically
i'm basically performing some kind of
linear transformation from one
one vector
to another vector and the weights
basically
is this transformation matrix that's one
way i like to think about it right okay
okay um
so in a matrix model
um
what we have is something
similar
not similar or again um but what we have
is
a situation where
we have
so the analogy first of all let me let
me spell out the analogy
the analogy is instead of having neurons
um
[Music]
that um are represented by vectors
right okay
um what with the idea here is that okay
we have matrix we have matrices
which are basically tensor products of
vectors so in other words i can for
example i could take the tensor product
of say two vectors x i
tensor x j
all right and then i can have a matrix x
i j right so likewise i can
i can have some correspondence where
the
equation of an artificial neural network
which is mapping the idea of a
perception or an artificial neuron
um is represented as a vector the idea
here is that the matrices right
um there's a sense in which i can i can
um isolate
some components of this matrix and i
could freeze
and this freezing procedure again
isn't is spelt out in the paper uh and
it's a long story
but i just want to spell out the basic
idea sure
i can basically isolate vectors in this
thing
in this matrix model
and tell me when you say you can isolate
them
okay so let me let me say another thing
here you mean like how they can be
decomposed and then you just pull out
one of them
yeah yeah so let's so in the matrix
models what we have is basically is let
me actually write down one of these
matrices okay
um x so it's x
a
sub dimension x i
m
n
so okay what is this thing right so
basically
it's basically um let's say that i runs
from one to three for now right so this
would be x1 x2
x3
and then i'll still have mn here
right
so um
so one thing i could do here
is assume that mn
is say
um completely diagonal
right so i can basically
make some approximation and collapse
this mn right
into
some x
so in other words here's x m n
right
and what i would now want to do is
basically only look at these components
here the diagonal components okay i can
play with that for now and then you know
just look only at the diagonal
components of this amp no this
mn matrix and there's something that
allows you to say that it's
diagonalizable
yes there's something that allows me to
say that
right
um
and
so that's that's that's one that's one
thing you can do but the other
you know one of the things that we are
currently working on as we speak
in the follow-up paper is exactly
how to
turn this thing into a you know um
into a bona fide
um
into a bona fide learning architecture
similar to an artificial neural network
but the upshot is that if you look at
the equation that i wrote um oh why is
it not allow me to
okay those matrices
from when i was reading your paper if i
understand correctly it's something like
the bfss matrix models but then what i
was wondering is and this is my
rudimentary knowledge that the
a more general form of bfss is bmn
and it takes into account turn simon's
term and so on and it also is not in
minkowski space it's in pvp wave which
to me sounds as if it's more general
so i'm curious why didn't you use the
bmn model why did you choose to use bfss
good question i mean right now we're not
choosing in fact we're not even choosing
we're just trying to figure out okay
the idea is that there are all these
matrix models as you said bmn bfss ikkt
what we're really focusing on is to
actually liberate ourselves from really
um
we really want to
use that as a motivation
but not yet um
commit ourselves to any one of those
models actually
so the matrix model that we actually did
um commit ourselves to is something
called a qubit matrix model
and that was actually
authored by
you know motivated by lee smolin so the
idea would be in this cubic matrix model
is that
you have um
[Music]
you know
you have a lagrangian
okay
um
that has a matrix let me call this thing
um
a matrix
x
and so now but this matrix actually has
a kinetic term x dot squared now i'm
suppressing the mn indices here so it
has
okay
i'm suppressing it so it has kinetic
energy
and then it will have a potential
that depends on x except this potential
is cubic in x
so it's cubic in a sense because it's a
matrix
it's a commutator right
like this
because matrices remember their matrix
values so the products will be
commutators
and as a result the equations of motion
of these matrices
you know the dynamics of these matrices
classically
will be something that looks like x dot
right
is
there's some there's probably some
coupling here and we call it lambda is
going to be lambda
you know
x comma x
because i i have to take a derivative
with respect to x and if you look at
this thing here
right
the idea is that
you know if you look at this here this
is like
i want to now think of this x dot
as my y
right
um okay and and somehow this
you know
this um
x x commutator
right
could be massage into something that
looks like y
times a component of x
right that's the analogy here
okay
now we're not there yet okay so the idea
is that somehow the dynamics of a matrix
model
is
similar to the dynamics of like a you
know of basically how a neural network
um
is able to learn
to learn
maybe in a supervised way so in other
words if i present the sum the theory
with an output or something known so
like a known solution yeah the idea is
that can the theory maybe spit out new
solutions
okay or for example here's one one thing
we're playing with
um imagine that these matrix models
could spit out realizations of the
standard model so in other words because
they're n by n matrices
you know um so therefore it might
correspond to a group s-u-n or special
unitary group n
then you can imagine that basically s23
times sc2 cross u1 may pop out as
solutions of this theory okay
um and the idea would be like given that
we know that this is a solution right
you think of that as the output
the same way we present a picture of a
cat or a dog and have the
neural network learn that
the same way we uh we're using a matrix
model and the dynamics of the matrix
model itself
right as a learning um architecture so
there's nothing external to the system
it's sort of like you know in it's part
of the system itself via its dynamics
its equations of motion
um and the idea here is if you if you're
on a one-to-one correspondence between a
learning architecture via neural
networks
um and
the dynamics of the matrix model
if we're able to make this
correspondence between x and and you
know this correspondence okay right
um so let me see if i can make this a
cleaner statement here so on one side i
have a artificial neural network and
right it has dynamics why
maps
i'm sorry you know input
sure
goes to output
and then what happens is that what's
going on here
the weights then get adjusted so the
weights are the things that actually get
adjusted in this learning right the
weight get optimized
likewise if i have a matrix model
and then there's something like the
standard model
as a solution
can we use can we use um
can we use the dynamics
can we use um let me see hold on a
second
in the paper did you focus or restrict
yourself to restricted boltzmann
machines or did you try out others
so far we um we we restricted ourselves
to um
hot feel like models
which um in some cases can be adapt you
know can be made
um
can have a semblance or you know rbms
restricted both machines i see and
there's the reason for that is just
simplicity
the reason for that is um generality
generality and and um it's yeah and
simplicity at the moment but we're
definitely keeping an eye out for other
other ways but let me so this that's
right so the idea here is that this
correspondence here is
instead of input output via the
artificial neural network
right um the matrix model the diff the
input now would be
the dynamic like the equations of motion
so we use the equation of motion itself
as a learning mechanism and the idea now
is that what are the weights how are the
weights being adjusted and we the idea
here is that
the things that get adjusted might be
the parameters of the standard model
because one of the big unresolved things
and
in um
theories of everything and like string
theory or even brand unified theories is
that you can spit out solutions or
realizations of the standard model but
as you know because of the latin this
issue of the landscape it's hard to tune
those parameters
so we're saying okay embrace that
but really what's going on maybe that
the universe is actually
learning and you know um it's somehow
you know
finds a solution if the solution is
stable in some sense stable meaning that
it's it's because these weights are
being adjusted
um
and the idea could be that
these weights
that are being adjusted will correspond
to the parameters of the standard model
so it's a big dream at the moment
um and it's a research program but we're
kind of in the middle of it right now
you know while you work with lee lee has
this idea of evolutionary black holes
and that in the genesis of each black
hole is another universe with
differently tuned constants and it's
predictive in the sense that
if we're in the typical member of the
space of universes we should see certain
formations of black holes be maximal
because the universe is constantly
trying to maximize the amount of black
holes it creates now is that similar to
this was this spawned by it
is it a question can this can that be
derived from this is it distinct yeah
i mean so lee
um to my memory you know
was the person that came up with the
landscape um
idea in that in that in that instant in
that um picture of black holes spawning
and being used as a mechanism
to determine not to determine but to
populate this landscape um with
different parameters of our standard
model for example so of the coupling
constants so it's um
so
that i would say this is um in that
spirit for sure because obviously for
many years i've been talking with lee
about how do we get around the issues of
how theories might determine
the the values of the standard model and
what mechanisms
um exist so one of the things i paid a
lot of attention to when i worked in
string phenomenology
right which is how string theory can
give us back the real world
was basically yeah i mean how you know
this was a big question um
and
one way out of course is that
if string theory gave you something like
um
um like
like eternal inflation then the idea
there was that the the different parts
of the universe that are inflated would
populate
the stamp you know the different
parameters and we happen to be living in
one of them so that's one you hit the
jackpot type of idea
um the other one
so but you know i've always kept an open
mind about other alter other ways of
thinking about maybe there's something
about the theory itself that's
determined in this and so the idea here
is to really simply
put a learn to think that maybe there's
some kind of learning in this in the
sense of artificial neural network
um but instead of it being a neural
network is the degrees of freedom
instead of being a neural network it's
actually the matrices which are now the
fundamental degrees of freedom that are
playing the role of the perception with
perceptrons and then the weights are
being adjusted the hope is that it's
going to be the parameters of the
standard model that's it that's it
interesting
but
one out one out i would say to get to
give myself an out here is that a quote
from albert einstein you know if we knew
what we were talking about we wouldn't
call it research so so there's a part of
me that i'm we're still confused about a
couple of things which is why it's great
talking to smart people like yourself so
as i just read the title of the
paper before i actually dived into it
what i thought may sorry has read the
abstract of the paper before diving into
it i thought perhaps it was something
like okay the weights change and the
weights change in such a manner that if
you follow them they look like particles
along a trajectory that's interesting
tell me more about that um that's
interesting with each pass there's
obviously a changing of the weights
can this changing of the weights be seen
as a trajectory and then if so can that
trajectory map onto what we think the
particle's trajectory should be
that's a great no no no that's a really
good idea it's a really good idea and
let me think about i'll get back to you
that's a really good idea actually
in a sense you know a way that you're
right you know because if you think
about this let me say one thing about
that sure
so let me um get back to this um
uh
this sure thing
so one one way to think about matrix
theory so you know to give some
because these abstract matrices now let
me imagine that i'm in three dimensions
so i have um you know
x sorry z
x y
and now i'm gonna put a particle in
three dimensions
so i'm to call this the location of this
particle
i'm going to give it it's of some vector
x from the origin right and obviously i
can look at the components of this
vector
right so let me just uh um so there's
some component of the vector i'm going
to take that vector sign off and label a
component x i where i goes from 1 to 3.
all right
so x1 is x x2 is y x3 is z
right
um it's good so now i'm gonna now think
about this particle confined to live on
a sphere
okay right
and now the sphere has some basically
some um
some basic area unit area okay
good
now
the picture in string theory is that
actually these matrices
correspond to the correspond to the
configuration of a of a
of a particle in string that we call a
d0 brain so actually this will be a zero
dimensional
um particle but it's fuzzy
so it so what happens is that
in
smooth continuous space times x i is
just some vector that will denote any
any position on my surface
but the fact that x i and x j for
example don't commute they correspond to
these d0 brains so but the idea is i
have these d0 brains
sitting around here
and they're strings that basically are
attached to these zero brains so that
when they cross each other um you know
brain one
um the d0 particle
is a d0 brain right yeah
d corresponds with dirichlet meaning
that a string ends on it with a
dirichlet bounce transition and it ends
at a point right so then you can now
focus on this point particle but it
differs from an ordinary point particle
in that it doesn't commute the same way
x and
p don't compete in quantum mechanics in
this case
x1 and x2 is not going to commute so
what that corresponds to this thing
called can i make a quick aside for the
audience please please whenever you have
a dp brain so pm just is an integer
that means the spatial dimension so if
you ever hear d6 brains it means it's a
seven dimension because you have to plus
one for time so right now d0 essentially
means point but you could still have
world lines which is what i believe is
captured in the bfs very nice model so
like what you just said this will be a
d2 brain
and that will be a membrane
for example
yeah just it helps clarify sometimes
these
small terms i know when i was learning
which by the way just so you know as a
confession stefan i i try my best to
study for each
interview assiduously and this one there
was a personal family matter that i had
to get to and so put a monkey wrench in
my
studying for this and for the past 10
days or so i've i knew nothing i knew no
turned simon's i knew no pantry aj and i
don't even know how to pronounce that i
basically had to learn all of this and i
still know a modicum of it just to prep
for this so even before this i didn't
know what a d zero brain was
so i'm saying this because these are
questions i had and i'm sure the
audience as they're watching would have
similar questions
wonderful
right so that's as you correctly pointed
and a d1 a d1 brain would be a
string that's right
and
therefore d zero brain will be a point
particle
and so the idea here is that the is that
the d0 brain
is the matrix that i just talked about
matrix theory corresponds to the
position
of a d0 brain in a non-commutative or
so-called fuzzy space-time
so that's a nice picture to have in your
mind when we're thinking about
matrix theories what they could describe
they're describing the motions of these
d zero brains but in a space time that's
not commutative now we're not it's not
only describing that and that's just one
limit of the theory where it's doing
that but it's a useful
thing to think about and another way you
can think about it too is uh
the membrane for example you can think
of it basically as a collection of these
zero brains that come together to form
the membrane so the basic building
blocks in this matrix there are these d
zero brains and the things they can do
and why is that interesting for the
insight that you have there
because when i think about the
interaction of these zero brains for
example it corresponds to the commutator
x i x j
right
and if this is in some comparison
correspondence to wij the weight
matrices of a learner that you're
talking about
then remember a potential a potential
energy
right determines basically the
trajectory of the particle yeah so i
think here i think you have it's a
really nice insight you have so i
definitely will take it seriously and
and think about it that corresponds
you know sometimes i say that it's it's
often useful for people who watch this
podcast to watch it once and
be befuddled and not understand and it's
basically in the second passing that you
get the true understanding the re the
way that i like to think about it is
that
one is thirsty like
they're curious they're they're
inquisitive and so they want to drink
but often it's
it's best often it's not always the case
and it's best to try and drink from the
fire holes not because to you're going
to fail drinking from the fire hose but
at least the point is to get wet i think
wheeler said that people are trying to
drink but the point is to get wet so
how about i'm going to take a couple
sentences from your paper with this
abstruse
unfathomable language for most people
then we're going to break them down term
by term so that afterwards people can go
through and decipher it and understand
what was meant
sure
okay so i believe this is just the
abstract of the turn simon's modified gr
so churn simon's modified gravity is an
effective extension of general
relativity that captures leading order
gravitational parity violation so first
of all there's turn simons we're going
to explain that effective extension
going to explain leading order going to
explain and gravitational parity
violation so what is chern simons
very good
his name after um of course um to the
authors um
someone who i who i consider a friend
and a mentor jim simons
a mathematician and
billionaire philanthropist
and polymath
and overall great and overall great guy
[Music]
he's he's one of actually
he's one of the most humor funniest
people he's like you know people i know
he
he just he's uh
he makes me
anyway so
jim is um
he makes one sense the architects of
yeah it makes me laugh um
and of course his um
his um
collaborator um chern
um
so churn science is based on this piece
of math um which is a
magical piece of math um and
that basically has to do with something
called
um
invariant forms okay so if i give you a
manifold a manifold
you know
can i characterize
um can i characterize
um
properties of this manifold and in some
cases topological properties of the
manifold so for example one thing you
can if you have a donut you can
characterize how many holes a manifold
can have without
no matter how much you deform the
manifold locally can right there's an
invariant which is the number of holes
that it has an invariant because no
matter how i change coordinates whatever
i do smoothly to this metaphor this
thing is going to be so is there a way
to mathematically
measure these types of topological
things and
what jim and simon's interns discovered
was a new way a new a new characteristic
class
um called the turn signs a new invariant
called transaction and what's special
about it
for physicists is that it's um
right
if you know the degrees of freedom
already like of our gauge theory for
example so now let me get down to earth
here so if i give you a gauge theory the
gauge theory is described like like
electromagnetism or yank or the standard
model by a connection right so or gauge
potential or the photon field right the
photon field is this thing called a mu
right
and the turn simon's theory says that if
i give you can you see this
no
all right so i'm not going to share a
screen
um
so
we're informed that if i give you an
electromagnetism a mu when mu runs from
zero to four this is the graph of x x um
right
it's a four dimensional object right so
the zero component of this is some
scalar quantity and then the x y and z
will be the spatial part i so this is a
zero and this will be a i okay so
that'll be four dimensions now this
this thing is actually
in electromagnetism
um
i can use this basically to determine
basically the electric and the magnetic
fields right
so that but it's all all the all the
information of the electrical magnetic
field is contained in amy which is a
connection they call the connection
because
if i take
covariant derivatives of this connection
or i take you know this if i move this
around this connection around some
some um
in a gauge theory
in other words and i could define
curvature
wait this thing is
that's weird okay
so i'm going to start again
you can define this so-called field
strength tensor
i know this is review for a lot of
people but just for completion
and basically by taking derivatives
um
of um
where this is partial derivatives with
respect to zero x y and z yeah i could
define this object so here's the
beautiful thing about turn signs
turn simon's theory tells you that if i
know f mu and u and i
and i can get it from a mu i could
define this invariant in three
dimensions which is just
a
let me say
tensor
f
and what i mean by this tensor it's
really an anti-symmetric tensor product
right so the churn simon's environment
calls it it's a let me call it the wedge
product okay very good
it is a wedge so i just i didn't want to
mystify people but it's what we call a
wedge
that's right
so a wedge f is in fact related to this
proportional to this turn signs of
variant
and this thing a a y f
they appear to be local quantities they
are when i say local quantities they're
not topological
right but when i take the wedge product
right and i integrate this over
like say if i have four dimensions and i
take a three dimensional boundary
m3
m3 that basically this thing is going to
be this thing is an invariant
right
um it's going to measure some kind of
topological it's going to measure
topological environment okay and when
you say it's an invariant do you mean
doesn't matter which m3 you take you'll
get the same value or what
um
like what's exactly is being invariant
here the value of this
oh yes yeah so this thing is something
if this thing is sum yet if this thing
is um
you know this thing is some some um
um
let me see
it's some integer
modulo something which i'm not
remembering right now but basically this
um integer modulo something which i
forget what what it is is um it's the
environment
um
so
that's
now
that's the math side of it and i'm by no
means a dif a differential geometer i'm
just a physicist
um i can just now tell you so that's
what that is mathematically
but there's a lot to in the math
literature right right and it's all
right it was a great math it was a
tremendous mathematical discovery but
the thing that's amazing is that turn
simon's theory has found itself
at home
and
you know nobel prize winning um
discoveries in physics like
when jim and chern were coming up they
had
no idea it would actually
be applied
you know
they just made this mathematical
discovery
um and now like you know anywhere from
the fractional quantum hall effect
it's it's you know it's found there um
in the standard model
it it's it's a key it plays a key role
in establishing anomalies and anomaly
cancellation in fact
the churn simon's term i can say
something even cool about this
in the standard model
that turns simon's form
what's called a turn signs form which is
as i said
a wedge f
right
um
[Music]
um
that's for of a certain dimension
correct it's like one dimension yeah
disorder so in this case this is in
three dimensions yeah i see i see let's
be in three dimensions it could be also
in four dimensions three or four
dimensions right ah i didn't so a web
jeff right so um
there's a so this
a wedge f here
um
and it turns out that
is
proportional
to a a current so in the standard model
we have currents right you know the
electromagnetic current
um
and one of the most one of the most
important things in the standard model
is that these currents
are conserved so for example i look at
you know current going in is equal to
current coming out which is a statement
that
d mu
of the current j mu right
right is zero
right
but you know this comes from actual
equation that says that
you know um
this is basically
coming from the statement that d mu
f mu nu
right is j nu
right so if i take another derivative of
this thing then by definition you see it
comes from maxwell's equations
so what's important here it turns out
that this is no longer the case
in the standard model when i turn on
quantum corrections
this is a major this is the so-called
the abj anomaly but actually this
couldn't be when i turn on quantum
corrections
this is proportional to d
um
d
of the turn simons
i'm being schematic here okay yeah and
when you say when you turn on quantum
corrections what do you mean by that
um add a turn simon's term
very good when i to me to say when i
when i say turn on quantum corrections
is that if i look at basically um
say the interaction of um
in quantum electrodynamics if i say i
look at a photon that basically
um
you know i can take you know electron
and it could scatter off in you know um
of a photon right this is like an
electron e prime
um i can imagine like doing things like
having another photon like here right
that will be a quantum effect and this
is now starts looking like it's
something called
um
well
but you can have other quantum effects
uh
so-called loop diagrams
and the one there's one special one
called a triangle diagram like this
where i have an electron loop for
example
going around going around
and then
um
photons coming in
like this
so i can have basically this type of
quantum effect this quantum effect if
you go and calculate it using fimen's
you know
um rules
will give you
this thing here i see
and this is the famous result of uh
adler bell and jakeev
um
the abj anomaly so it turns out the
standard model will do this and this is
not good
yeah and this is not good why
oh
so it's not good because
the big deal there is that it actually
um it violates the fundamental principle
of quantum mechanics which is it
violates unitarily
the conservation of
probability um
um
so
you can probably see where it's coming
from because if you can now think about
this loosely as the probability current
right
then
i now this is no longer zero and in
quantum mechanics the
current probability current has to be
conserved
all right
so
so it turns out that turn simon's theory
is a part of the standard model
right
and
how
it just so happens though that the
standard model
all the contributions of all the
currents
correspond to all the different forces
completely cancel
so when i sum over all the currents
okay
um i sum of all the anomalies it turns
out that they
it vanishes in a standard wall so that's
what makes our standard model quite
unique actually mathematically
that that cancels anomaly so that's
another place churn simon's theory shows
up
okay
and then the
the other place that shows up is
actually in string theory and string
theory the turn simon's theory shows up
to actually actually
in a magical way it also plays a role in
canceling the anomalies in string theory
as well
it's called a green schwarz mechanism
right right right current simon's
gravity now is another place um that i
played um a role in
in
pushing over my career as um a way of a
new way of another
oh
a way of thinking about gravity that has
the turn simon's term in it
can we go back to the other page where
we have the anomaly
this one
before that
okay
see oh my god this is a mess i need to
yeah that's fine okay you can
see on the right hand side
what an anomaly is is when there's a
violation of the conserved current but
i'm unsure is that all that anomalies
are are there other types of anomalies
other than quantum anomalies in other
words whenever someone says there's an
anomaly are they always referring to
that the right-hand side is no longer
zero
very good so let me um
good question so let me just say another
in general if i this is a general
statement i'm making about anomalies
okay for any current
um that is conserved that's right that
is conserved
um
i'm going to put on the right hand side
the letter a
if it's not if it's not equal to 0 and
there's an a
that a is called the anomaly that's
literally what it means so when a is 0
then the current is conserved and
the question you're asking is can an
anomaly arise um
in a non-quantum way
um that's a good question i you know um
um
so one thing
the calculations that are done to
determine the anomaly to my knowledge
are all
um are all quantum
[Music]
considerations
um but i see no reason why you can't you
know in some
theory which i can't recall right now
generate an anomaly classically
okay so another question that
especially undergrads has i know i had
is let's say you have the client gourd
and then they say well it's not unitary
it doesn't conserve
probability across time well what's the
big deal about that because so what if
you add some extra let's say lumps on
the probability distribution why can't
you just simply constantly re-weight it
down to normalize it so why can't you
normalize it at every given
infinitesimal moment
is my question making sense do you
understand or should i restate it you
could always that's right you can always
re-normalize that's what we call
re-normalizing that's you know you can
always re-normalize
um but if you find yourself in a
situation that even when you
re-normalize it still gets violated then
you're in trouble i see i see yeah so is
there a way of determining a priori
whether that a on the right-hand side of
the bottom equation is re-normalizable
or is that some large
prospect of many people that takes their
lives sometimes
or is this fairly simple to see this is
not renormalizable
very good
um that's right so
the
very good the a that's generated
um
actually
has a divergence as well
and that that divergence when i say
divergence i mean
there's an infinity
when i actually
you know take
um
when i integrate out when i integrate to
um you know
to high high momentum right in this
because remember this a is coming from
the internal legs
um
and
that noise i would say that that's um
getting into um
you know
um
no this this is a question the question
that i think this is pointing to is what
is it about the anomaly that's leading
you to deduce
that you that the fear is not
re-normalizable and i'm sorry that the
theory is not unitary
and
this has to do with something called
award identities and what the minute you
have these anomalies you can show that
these word identities
um
which are identities having to do the
unitarianity of the theory um you know
it's violated
i don't yeah i would i don't have a i i
need to think more about that i don't
have an intuition
for it
sure it's a it's a well-defined question
it's just that um
yeah sure and then also looking at this
middle equation the one that has the sum
with the d and the cs why is it a
difficult problem to get rid of an
anomaly when it seems like well if my
understanding is correct you add a
certain term to a lagrangian if it's as
simple as that in some cases it is so
you add a certain
in this case a turn-simus term perhaps
then an interaction term with the churn
simus term but you add a term
nonetheless then you go through this
standard
nodarian
identity to get the charge current and
then you find that you get an extra term
which completely cancels it so why can't
you just
why is
can you not just reverse that process to
try and find out what terms should i add
in order to cancel this
or is it like highly non-trivial
no there no that we do have these
anomaly canceling conditions
um in the standard model and what that
boils down to
is
for the anomalies to cancel in the
standard model
the charge assignments you know the way
you identify the charges of the quarks
the leptons and you know the quarks and
electrons
um
and the color of the quarks
um
they um
and the gauge groups remember that's
what i mean by the color the iso span as
well as the you know the charges
um
the charges the assignments the fact
that the quarks have one you know
fractional charge is precisely because
when i add up the anomalies from all the
other interactions
um
so those charge assignments are the
things that actually are allowing this
anomaly to cancel i see interesting
interesting
yeah
stefan
i want to know what do you consider to
be a theory of everything the reason i
ask this is when i asked so well some
people say well it needs to incorporate
consciousness or it needs to explain the
origins of the universe some people just
say unify gravity in the standard model
what does a theory of everything mean to
you
it's a really good question
um well i mean i have um my ambitions
now are
um
i would say that for example if string
theory
um
was able to
provide
like as a solution and a you know that
meets the standard of what a solution is
in string theory that gives us back
say something
like like an early like at the very
least an early universe scenario that is
consistent with observation
um
maybe it's inflation maybe it's an
alternative to inflation
i would literally say that string theory
therefore
modulo
it's difficulty and tell me why that
solution is preferred over other
solutions would be a fear of everything
all right uh um and then i would and
then i would add about you know the more
like the questions of like okay higher
level organizational properties of
matter
including life and including
consciousness i have some thoughts about
that too but i would say that um you
know at this level i would call that a
theory of everything so it sounds like
that's been a
a common thread throughout your entire
career because around 2000 2001 or so
but you've been working at it probably
in 2000 you had the inflation of the
debris and debris annihilation
and that seemed at least seemed to
produce something that looks akin to the
big bang and i believe you use some data
to show
i'm not sure if you
if you made a prediction and you showed
how it matches with prediction i'm not
sure about that but either way that
sounds like a through line
yeah so um i was trained as a string
cosmologist meaning that um you know
someone that knows both string theory
and enough cosmology enough of each okay
but certainly not a master of either
um
to
because back then this was you know 2000
1999 2000. the call was um
can we
some people some people felt string
theory wasn't developed enough some of
us felt it was developed enough to then
ask questions of can we reproduce
something like cosmic inflation so i
went to my first postdoc trying to do
that
and that was my take on how to do that
so i guess the fact that it was
published meant that you know it met
some standards um
and but one of the things it did do was
it opened the floodgates for other
string theorists and i certainly wasn't
the first and the only one
um
but anyway open the floodgates for
others to then
improve or develop different ideas but
similar
um ideas you know with string theory
that somehow these d brains are playing
some role
in um
and describing the early universe and
four dimensions out of 10 dimensions
did you do that work at ubc
very good um i
i spent a lot of my time thinking about
the idea when i was at ubc as a grad
student
but then i
really did it when i was a postdoc at
imperial college in london
did you have doubts about your own
mathematical ability or your own
that if whether or not you could not
that you wanted to maybe i'm sure you
had doubts should i go into this but
could you did you have the ability so
did you ever doubt your own ability big
time big time
yeah big time and i remember i um in
fact i remember when i was a graduate
student i knew i was deeply
interested in the big questions and i
but i actually
was going to settle for less and because
internally i didn't didn't feel i had i
had what it took and everybody else was
just really mathematical and really new
things that i could i didn't know and i
felt it was going to be such a learning
curve
um and i remember one time
um
um
that we had this visitor
that has come visit brown's physics
department
and um
he was of you know he was like one of
the most brilliant strengtheners and he
carried himself as if he was some kind
of guru i mean we used to walk a walk
like i was like is this guy some kind of
yogi or something
and his name was sumet das
right and he needs to come visit um the
strength theorists at brown and he'd be
there a week and he'd be there on on
weekends and one day i was in you know
hanging out and i
he started talking to me and i was like
why is this strength here is talking to
me
um
and i i then i asked him i said i felt
comfortable i was like is that something
that like you know if you want to do
strength theory um how good you do you
need to do this he goes no no no all you
have to do is be passionate about it and
just go for it and and somehow the way
he said it to me made me feel like well
maybe i can do this right
so i definitely i i owe i definitely
want to give i owe it to submit das you
know for for kind of playing that role
just saying hey you can do this
um
but you know that that still lives at me
that still looks at me i still feel
like i yeah i
you know my strengths are not with um
[Music]
you know knowing a whole bunch of math
although i love math and i love learning
from mathematicians and i you know um
you know there's a place
where we play we have to play in our
strengths and know what they are in my
case i'm you know kind of intuitive i
have pictures i play with thought
experiments
it's important to talk to people to have
soundboards and one of the things that's
very important to me
is actually having soundboards that are
not always experts in my field
yeah so i find things like this and be
very useful also to my research like
conversations like this
you're doing a service to physics
research
thank you thank you so what age was that
when you
met with that guy summit i believe his
name is summit doss
yes submit das um i was a first-year
graduate student
and i was actually trying to be an
experimentalist at the time
not not because it wasn't
experimental experimental work is as
hard or even harder than um than theory
work so
that's the asterisk for brian keating
yes exactly um
but um
i guess what i'm saying was that it was
a time where what my real interests were
i was suppressing it um
because i didn't think
so yeah it was
i don't know i think i was like 24 23
years old
i'm 50 now so yeah what advice do you
have because there are quite a few
people who are watching this who don't
have a background in university maybe
they have some training in mathematics
but that's it maybe some rudimentary
physics that they've seen from an mit
open courseware
video
but they want to understand
string theory m theory well string m
theory and loop quantum
and so on
but they don't feel like they have it in
them let's the average age of this
person who emails me this or leaves
comments about this tend to be 20 30 and
even 40. so i'm not sure if the age
differences give yield different advice
yeah
um i would say you know look if you
can't um
basically
yeah that's a that's a really good one i
mean it depends on you know whether or
not you can maybe
go back to some kind of school but there
are lots of you know online
presence now information online
like um i'm thinking about like even
things like
lenny suskin's course
um
but even like one thing i find really
interesting is that the perimeter
institute has um online they they have
made
um open you know they've made um their
online seminar series jump in like
listen to these seminars go online
um the other thing is um there are some
really good books now
so for example like lenny suskin has a
book called theoretical minimum
um
which i endorse the second i mean
they're really good i read them actually
you know um it's a good place to kind of
be sort of build some foundation and
then
actually go online and pull out some
problem sets and try playing working
with these problem sets and
get up you know join a group of friends
and work for these problem sets together
i mean practicing problems the reason
why you want to practice things like
problems that have been solved already
is that
you build an arsenal of of solve
problems and they they can be used as as
a launch pad to solve and solve problems
right so kind of getting a sense of
what's what's been solved out there and
then i actually recommend um one of the
reasons why i actually and this is not
an advertisement i literally wrote my
second book
um
precisely because i wanted to um
i wanted to um
um
fill a vax of a vacuum um in terms of
how people can start thinking about
research problem what what are the
cutting-edge things that we're thinking
about now and it was written very much
in the spirit of richard feynman's um
you know character physical law and
brief his brief history of time to kind
of carve some space out exactly for that
for that person who wants to get a sense
of what's out there you know what what
are people thinking about and what are
the unsolved problems and what are the
directions that people are afraid of or
is you know um
is holding the field back
from again from the opinion of a
you know so in other words imagine i'm
somebody's thesis advisor right
um like a phd thesis or a master's
thesis advisor and i and i
had to disappear for a year i would
leave this book with with that
thesis student right
so those are three things three three
concrete things go get your book get
what's the book the name of the book and
do you have it right in front of you
i don't have the i just gave my book
away to a student of mine
um
yeah the book is called fear of a black
universe an outsider's guide to the
future of physics that's the subtitle
now when i hear that to me it sounds
like a book about race and science is it
a book about that or exclusively about
that or minorly about that minorly about
that i'll say ten percent of the book is
about
is about um identity in science um of
course we can include race in that but
we can include personality different
modes of ways of thinking um you know
but the title was also a play it was a
you know it was a also a nod to one of
my favorite rap bands when i was in
college called public enemy
that's something you and i also have in
common not only are we from trinidad but
we used to rap although i think you used
to do the beatboxing i was more of a
beatbox than a beat maker i i wish i
could rap so at one of these days we
might have to do something together
that'd be great wouldn't it
yeah yeah okay getting okay you know
what first of all about brian key
brian keating's your friend correct
he's my best friend yeah yeah i'm gonna
prove to you that he's not your friend
okay see this
yeah
okay hold on
see that see that thumbnail
yeah yeah no friend no friend would
leave your thumbnail like that
that's the worst thumbnail i've ever
seen of anyone i'm i'm going to tell
brian to choose yeah you got to tell him
okay that's a good one i'm just that's a
joke i'm just kidding around but still
actually i don't actually
yeah i caught him in the middle of a
sneeze
and then he chose that
right right right i'm gonna i'm gonna
get on him i will get on him about that
okay how was the process of learning for
you changed now that you're older what
would if let's imagine you could advise
your young self practices to keep
practices to drop practices to adopt
you're advising your 20
maybe even 25 30 year old self
about what though about learning
something like string theory or learning
something like oh
yes yes yes yes i think
it's important
to combine practice with play
um so rather than you know if i you know
if i'm learning something like the
the equations of motion
coming from varying the string world
sheet action
for example
it's important that i not only know how
to correctly vary the oil in the ground
you know how to obtain the oil lagrange
equations
right
and why the calculus of variation
applies that applied for a point
particle would also apply for a string
uh worldsheet action
but it's important that once i get this
that i play with those equations i
literally play with them i move them
around i play with the rules of the
match i break the you know i actually
break the rules and see what happens
like the same way a kid plays with a toy
what would be an example of trying to
break the row
just making a mistake or what or making
a purposeful mistake and seeing where it
leads yeah make it literally make a
purposeful mistake and see where it
leads exactly
that's interesting um yeah so
i'm one for
playing with breaking the equation br
breaking the the equations um well you
know you know kids don't try it at home
so but this is definitely something you
can try at home
and
[Music]
you might learn something but when you
go out and you give a talk or you write
up you try to write a paper you're
obviously not going to
put that mistake there
but it's you do these things just to see
you know
um
again that's kind of like yeah that to
me is just like you know the idea of
playing with with um with things
what would be an example of a time that
you played you purposefully did
something incorrect in order to see
where it lead what would be the time
that that led to an insight
can you give me well i think i think the
paper that i wrote with um with michael
peskin and shaheen sheikh jabari on
leptogenesis well you know the origin of
matter of antimatter um we propose that
this can take place during the period of
early universe called cosmic inflation
um and that actually came from
um
putting a place filler in
so
you know so
how do you create matter of antimatter
well you need to exactly have an anomaly
um and then what i was doing was i
didn't know what the answer would be but
i put and i put the answer i needed to
be in there which clearly violated the
einstein equations right and then after
like you know like whatever i mean
thinking about talking about it having
sound boards it's important to have
soundboards
you know to have people that you can
talk with who will not judge you but
actually take something dumb that you
said and throw it back to you in some
meaningful more meaningful way so
michael peskin my pro soccer advisor was
that guy and shaheen was that guy
so
um and then next thing you know it takes
form and next
we discover well actually the real story
about that was that we were thinking
that it maybe was torsion this idea of
torsion that that would source the baron
asymmetry that turned out to not work
but again the torsion thing had a
tensorial structure
meaning the way the indices were moving
around
and um when i was i went to caltech that
year and i visited mark cameron the
great cosmologist mark kaminkowski and
then i was telling mark the idea and
mark goes oh you should take a look at
this paper i wrote it might be useful
and then when i look at the paper it had
actually for other reasons
it had
this turned simon's thing when i came
back to stanford we started playing with
that and it turned out to work
ah well that's an example of like um
so i don't know if that was like
deliberately making a mistake but it was
sort of like yeah i think that in this
case you put almost like
you're fudging you're literally fudging
it's what i signed it you put a fudge
factor in to make it work
right for dark energy in this case there
was no anomaly but you needed there to
be an anomaly because there is an
asymmetry we needed to be a harmless and
a yeah a harmless anomaly okay so for
the people listening when these when
there's that j in the current
j isn't always current as an electric
charge current
yes it can be other types of
conserved quantities
or certain quantities that need to be
conserved
yes
okay so what would
this so in that example it would look
like d mu and then j
mu at the top what would that j
represent for very consuming
okay
so this will be
the current associated with leptons so
the electron is an electron the
neutrinos are leptons right so these are
the leptons and there's a quantity
called a lepton
the lepton number
right
um the same way you have like an
electric charge there's actually a
electronic charge
and that leptonic charge it can be
violated by an anomaly
and that's that that one is fine because
it's a so-called global anomaly
it doesn't depend on space-time
and those anomalies sorry i want to make
sure i don't want to lose okay so you
said that the lepton charge can be
violated by an anomaly you mean to what
do you mean when it when you say it can
be violated by anomaly it's not just
because the way that i see it is that
you have your theory and then you find
out oh it's anomalous
it's not that oh i can make this
anomalous because i feel like i can make
any theory anomalous very good
so the left and the standard model the
lepton it turns out that the lepton
current is not anomalous
with exception and this is where the
exception is if you turn gravity on
there's a gravitational anomaly and that
is a gravity the thing that's doing that
is the gravitational churn-simus term
right
and
and it turns out that if you have a
gravitational configuration
meaning in the gravitational field that
gives you a non-vanishing turn simon's
gravitational term it could source
lepton number
right
um
so it can source
um in this case the production of lepton
so you may not say source it will create
leptons that's one way of thinking about
it
um
you know i want to talk about something
that it sounds like it's not
inspirational but it is there are
certain no-go theorems in physics and in
math but let's talk about physics
what are some examples of no-go theorems
that turned out to be a go theorem like
you could find your way around it
um
firstly let's explain to or you should
explain to the audience what a no-go
theorem is
very good a novo theorem is a statement
so i'll give you an example of a no-go
theorem and maybe i can
um
you know
um
actually let me
so a no-go theorem is weinberg's no go
through about um any adjustment
mechanism for the cosmological concept
so the statement says
that
you can't use um say in this case a
scalar field with a potential
um
to relax
to relax a cosmological concept
and then he went and like actually did
some calculations and showed that
actually if you had such a theory
that you cannot use that to cancel out
the cosmological constant
right
and that is true
but in that theorem in that
theorem there were some axioms or some
assumptions about in this case that
if that scale of field relaxes to a vac
a ground state remember the field is can
roll and then it when it gets its ground
state or to its minimum the minimum of
its
if that ground state is ponca
invariant
then
what weinberg said is complete is you
know is true
but if the vacuum state is not pronecare
invariant then
that assumption that no go theorem
doesn't apply because you've relaxed
that assumption so now you you have a
loophole
right so you can now try so then people
realize that by now constructing
so-called p of x theorems theories
these are
theories where the scale of field
is actually has a non-trivial kinetic
term
um and those theories have ground states
where the kinetic energy is still
non-vanishing
right and it's not a poincare invariant
vacuum so recent manifestations of
trying to solve the cosmological
constant problem
um
have by really good people have used um
those um
those types of relaxation mechanisms
that evade weinberg's no-go theorem or
evades
one of one of the assumptions of that
noble theorem
the reason i helped yeah yeah yeah it's
actually inspirational and the reason is
that it seems clear oh you have a no-go
someone says there is no way look this
is math this is physics there is no way
around it but then you realize well
there are hidden assumptions you
mentioned axioms i
i call them anthem memes which are just
unstated assumptions embedded in your
question or embedded in your statement
and one of my favorite ones is
is whitten i think it was just whitten
although it could be whitney weinberg in
1980 where he said okay if you want a
spin hack larger than spin half particle
and has a conserved a lawrence covariant
current
it it can't exist if it's massless and
then same with it can't
exist greater than one and be massless
and have a conserved stress energy
tensor and then so that seems to
indicate well there can't be a graviton
because graviton has spin too and
massless supposedly and no charge
supposedly but then
you and the assumption that was made is
was so
implicit that they never made it
explicit and they didn't realize i don't
know if they realized until someone else
i don't know maybe juan maldecina came
along and said well okay
that's right it it cannot exist in this
space-time but it can exist in another
space-time and i believe that's part of
the origin of the holographic principle
nice that's very good that's very good i
think um excellent point now i don't i
don't have a i don't remember
but i can um i think though that the
weinberg wouldn't theorem um wait it's a
wine river
does make an assumption about the
underlying space sign and i can see how
anti-deciduous space which is the space
stand
ads cft is based on holography um
that version
um i could see how that could avoid the
weinberg written theorem exactly because
in ads cft that's right it's um it is
beautiful in the sense that the
let me just for the re for the audience
to say that it basically is a theory
that says that
in gravity and in one higher dimension
so let's say i had a four-dimensional
gravity theory it's completely encoded
in a non-gravitational theory living at
the boundary of that four-dimensional
theory with no gravity and that theory
that has no gravity is related to yang
mill's theory where there's no gravity
and the idea here is that where does
gravity how does gravity emerge
and one i think simple minor idea is
that in the yang mills theory you can
have condensates or degrees of freedom
that emerge that come together
collectively
right
to then form the graviton which would be
a version of this weinberg if i need to
get a graviton to space sign yeah i have
to build it out of the
degrees of freedom of the young mills
theory and that i can see how that
weinberg wouldn't theorem would have to
be evaded
can you explain why is it that the
graviton is said to have spin too when
for some for people who are
just learning about this for the first
time seems arbitrary well why are you
saying the graviton has spin to why are
you saying that there's a particle
associated at all with gravity because
gravity we've been told since we've been
teenagers it's not a force
it's the curvature of time since space
time and so on so firstly why does there
have to be a particle associated with
gravity in the same way there are
particles associated with other
interactions and second why does it have
to be spin two
yeah so the spin will correspond in this
case to the helicity of the particle
and just like engage
i mean if you look at a gauge field a mu
the index mu
now becomes basically related to the um
to the the um if i have a
electromagnet wave propagating the
polarization tensor e mu
is carrying the information
about the spin about all the helicity in
this case
meaning the momentum projected onto how
the particle is spinning
okay that's the helicity so you can
trace that back to the fact that this
gauge field has one
tensile vector index and spacetime index
so if i now have a spin two particle out
i have two of these indices now and
that's exactly the tensorial form
of the transverse traceless
gravitational perturbation
however to say it's a quantum particle
would spin
to
is an extra i would say
thing general relativity
doesn't tell you anything about you know
that
if i look at general relatives it's a
classical theory but if i go through and
make the same procedure
and say oh look the same way i do
quantum field theory i work in minkowski
space there's a procedure right perturb
the field
the gravitational field there's a tiny
perturbation and then define some kind
of state that
in some sort of modes
you know oscillations with creation
annihilation operators
that's where you're gonna start seeing
the spin two quantum numbers come pop
out
but from where i stand that isn't a
that's not you know that's not part of
general relativity that's an extra
assumption of doing quantum field theory
right in a weekly curve space
yeah
i'm sure you've heard weinstein say that
maybe we shouldn't be quantizing gravity
that we should be geometrizing the
quantum
have you taken a look at geometric unity
i have i have taken a a deep look at it
yes
okay what are your thoughts
well i just well you know i think well
there's it's um the mathematics is
definitely very you know very um
advanced
um
[Music]
i think i think
i think it's a beautiful idea actually i
think it's a really nice idea the idea
that i don't know what the word is but
you have you start off with four
dimensions the lorentz group and then
you do this you
you you think of all the components all
the ten components
um in this four dimensional world
um um you let that vary so that
therefore you have a bundle structure
like a fiber and all these components
are now a fiber fiber over this four
dimensional space
and that somehow
then gives you
um
the something that starts looking like a
grand unified group maybe it's so10 or
something like that
so the 10 components of this fiber is
like m4 fiber over so10 maybe
again i'm bastardizing eric's idea but
sure i like this idea that somehow
you just start with that data and then
then you the mathematics just naturally
gives you this extra gauge structure
that seems to have and better understand
well now the devil's in the details and
i know that there are some criticisms
that need to be ironed out but i think
that's kind of what we do when we do
do when we do good theory you put it out
you give it your best shot
you know and especially if you're doing
it alone
um i think that
then others jump in and then they they
improve it or they
they find a mistake that that's that's
actually that's what that's actually
what the refereeing profit process is
anyway any paper that i write
right well the first thing is i write
the paper or i work it out i do
something i get far enough where i feel
confident i have something but there's
always time places where i have blind
spots i give a seminar and the seminar
is usually where i get feedback before i
put the paper out then i put the paper
out
and then i put up for publication and
then usually the referees the referees
further help me um
understand what's going on actually and
if they find a bad
that is not publishable fine i learned
something new i move on uh that's
happened to me many times so i think
that
you know um
that component is missing
i think that component is
yeah i think that component is um
is missing
precisely because you know eric is um
you know sort of going out a lot of this
alone
and um i encourage him he put it out and
i think that people should read it and
take it very seriously and and and play
with it and um and scrutinize it and i
think that there might be some gems in
there okay even if it's not it doesn't
turn out to pan out to be correct in you
know um
in terms of what it's
what it's trying to solve which is
unifying the standard model with general
relativity in this new way
at the very least for me at least i i've
i'm reading it or i've read it so that i
can learn some things and i'm definitely
i've definitely learned some interesting
things and it got me thinking about
um unification in in different ways now
so it's been it's valuable we should
have more of that
have you read wolfram's paper or
wolfram's physics project
um a little bit not i didn't you know
the answer is
i intend to i intend to when i have more
of some time yeah um i do know that it
does it is related to some ideas and
graph theory i also think that again
it's a it's um some nice ideas out there
it may strike some resonance with other
things like matrix theories and other
approaches
um
but i'm all one for let's populate
the the theory landscape with ideas and
let's scrutinize it and learn from it
the reason i ask that is that there is a
direct quote from you i believe in your
auto didactic universe paper about how
there's how reality works and then
there's how we model it and our models
are somewhat like approximations but
then they get closer and closer to the
real world and then you start to wonder
how much of the real world
is these computational techniques
underneath
i don't have the exact line but it
reminds me
of
almost verbatim that's what wolfram
thinks he thinks because computers are
so
powerful this is not exactly what he
thinks or why he thinks and i'm just
paraphrasing but computers are so
powerful
and the computation under his models are
so general and so powerful and so
predictive in us in a certain sense that
perhaps that is what the universe is
it's computation underneath
that's beautiful
um i'll have to
well that's beautiful that's what we
said but
it's amazing you forget what you write
okay i know i don't want to
take up too much more of your time i i
can keep honestly i can keep talking to
you for it
because we should do we should um i do
have to run off and have dinner actually
with jim gates who's somebody i think
you should have as well you know i would
like to i also wanted to bring to the
forefront for because there are quite a
few mathematicians and physicists who
watch this podcast and for the physicist
in particular there's some i'm
interested in unification that's the
name of the channel theories of
everything
there's
been proposed for quite some time now
almost 20 years now that geometric
algebra should be seen as the standard
force for unification or the standard
language of unification david hestonians
i believe
he's agreed to be on the show i just
have to book a date with them
categorical category theory as well so
categorical unification whatever that
means that was proposed by quite a few
people james weatherwall comes to mind
and elaine landry had a book on quantum
sorry on category theory for
philosophers but had a few sections on
category theory as applied to physics
for the purpose of unification
so i'm extremely interested in that and
bring
a bit more attention to that there are
there's cole furry have you heard of col
cole furry yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so i
want to have her on i've just yeah she's
she's done very cool stuff yeah yeah
i i love her little her mini youtube
series on the quaternion
and then chiara marletto
i want to have on however
i don't know she's like
ghosting me i don't doesn't matter how
many times i send her an email she will
not respond and i don't know why i don't
know if it has if
what's the name chiara marletto it's the
student of david deutsch
oh yeah i don't know her at all um um
yeah i don't know her at all
you got to get going i got to maybe half
the question
no no but let's no let's reschedule and
continue we could we can do that yeah
i'm around so um
i just literally just got set up today
so now that i got the system going just
let me know and i'm happy to continue
talking um
and i'm also like a little bit tired and
frazzled i think the next time you get
me um now that i know kind of your style
i'll be able to um you know do some some
some better stuff yeah sure all right
well you did great oh thanks man
whatever is better it will be accepted
yeah
the podcast is now finished if you'd
like to support conversations like this
then do consider going to patreon.com
c-u-r-t j-a-i-m-u-n-g-a-l
that is kurt jaimungle it's support from
the patrons and from the sponsors that
allow me to do this full-time every
dollar helps tremendously thank you